this is a production of Cornell
University
all right so thank you everybody for
coming I'm really excited to be here
finally after five semesters with all of
my research that I'm going to present to
you today and what we're going to talk
about is primarily LEDs as Neil
mentioned and specifically with their
applications with lettuce and tomatoes
and then I went a little bit further and
started to develop a curriculum
supplement for middle schoolers for how
can we get the next generation
interested in plant science and how can
we use current research to really build
on that interest so let's start out with
just a little definition what are LEDs
LEDs are light emitting diodes I know
most of you are probably familiar with
them and even if you're not aware that
you're familiar with them they're really
becoming more and more popular in
everyday life here is just you know the
basic idea of an LED you know you can
have a blue LED a red LED a green LED
any color that you want they're really a
lot smaller than traditional light bulbs
and they can be found in a lot of
applications such as these hobbyists
computer decorative applications also
everyday applications with now we're
replacing fluorescent and other forms of
light bulbs with these LED light bulbs
they're more energy efficient as well as
for us what we're particularly
interested in are the horticultural
applications of LED lights since they do
have a lot of flexibility in spectrum
and color that opens up a lot of
opportunities for photo biological
research and we do tend to pursue that
research in greenhouses and growth
chambers and with a lot of food crops
but what we focused on was lettuce and
tomatoes but why lettuce and tomatoes
there's a lot of reasons one of which
could be you know O'Neal told me I need
to focus on lettuce and tomatoes but
really lettuce and tomatoes are some of
the most popular food crops in the
United States so they make a really big
impact on the agricultural market so of
course they're a crop that we want focus
on
so first let's talk about lettuce my
lettuce project looks specifically at
quality yield and biomass efficacy of
several different hydroponic varieties
in a cultivars in response to high
pressure sodium and LED lighting in the
greenhouse and this lighting was all
supplemental in nature Noakes he's no
sole source lighting at this point so
the context behind this was we were
working with the company CEA fresh farms
and this company wanted to develop a
hydroponic lettuce production system but
they didn't know what cultivars they
wanted to go forward with and they
didn't know if they wanted to use high
pressure sodium lights which were a kind
of an industry standard or if they
wanted to go with LEDs which were pretty
up-and-coming technology and they've
been hearing a lot about them but they
didn't know a whole lot about
applications beyond that we also had a
lighting sponsor for this project luma
grow they helped us out a lot by
actually providing us the LED systems
that we ended up using for our lighting
treatments so this experiment consisted
of three well this this portion
consisted of three experiments
experiment one was an initial
investigative variety trial it took
place between February and December of
2017 and we had we looked at NFT
hydroponics is whose nutrient film
technique hydroponics and what that
means is that we had these these
channels we're just a thin film of water
flowed over the bottom of the channel
continuously at all times we had a one
large nutrient reservoir where we
adjusted pH and EC daily or weekly
depending on the conditions within the
reservoir and the objectives for this
where we were looking at 25 varieties of
lettuce just under high pressure sodium
lights to get an idea of their
performance in terms of tip burn bolting
how big in general do these varieties
get what was the color quality and just
overall what were their perform
winces so the outcome of experiment what
one was this table which is you know
it's a lot of information really big
table and we came up with there a pretty
general qualitative responses there were
no quantitative responses at this point
it was all just observations of say was
tipper and observed or not was bolting
observed or not what was the general
size is the general color and what was
the general type of lettuce that we were
growing but for experiment two these are
the lettuce varieties that we ended up
going with so after we had all of these
observations made the company decided
that these were the varieties that they
were most interested in based on we
wanted a good separation of or a good
selection of red and green lettuces we
wanted some head lettuce we wanted some
leaf lettuce winded some Romain's so we
wanted a good variety in that selection
for experiment two this ran from January
to May of 2018 so this year and this
consisted of three harvest cycles with
what we now did was we split the table
previously there were 20 channels all
under the high pressure sodium but at
this point we split it into two ten ten
channel and if teas they still shared
the same nutrient reservoir so the root
system was still exposed to sink
conditions and what we wanted to do now
is after we chose us thirteen varieties
we wanted to compare how high pressure
sodium and led affected these two
different or these thirteen different
varieties for this one we knew we
weren't going to get really strong
statistical data because our sample size
per variety was going to be pretty small
so what we were doing was we were
looking for what qualities that we
wanted to further investigate further on
in the experiment so for cycle 1 for all
cycles we collected data on yield as
well as electrical efficacy for cycle 1
we collected data on Brix
for cycle 2 we had some taste test data
and for cycle three we collected height
and diameter data our environmental set
points were maintained throughout the
three harvest cycles with ph of 5.5 to
6.5 EC at 1.8 to 2.2 and our air
temperatures are 21 during the day and
17 Celsius during the night so what what
did our treatments look like well as I
mentioned we had high pressure sodium
vs. LED so what does I really mean this
is a spectrograph output of what our
treatments look like in general our high
pressure sodium spectrum tends to be
heavier in the yellow and red so with
very little blue you can see that the
gray here is the high pressure sodium
spectrum whereas our LEDs had blue
around 440 nanometer and red at around
660 nanometer and our treatment was a
20% blue 80% red treatment for the LEDs
in each array provided a supplemental
light level of about a hundred and
eighty micro moles for lighting control
we employed an additional strategy of
lassie lassie is lighting and shade
system integration and this is a
computer algorithm that was developed
here at Cornell and what this allowed us
to do was enter a target DLI a daily
light integral for both of our systems
where we could monitor the instantaneous
levels of light with a quantum sensor at
each table and we could shoot for a 17
mol per day target which is what's
generally recommended for lettuce in the
greenhouse both tables were controlled
independently so we had two of these
sensors so each of them had a different
amount of light on per day potentially
or different intensities at different
times and as you can see as the cycles
progressed through the months less and
less light was being provided to the
plants and this is because basically
just due to seasonality as we got
further into the spring more ambient
light would be available to the plants
we
tried to preserve the treatment effect
by keeping the shade cloth closed as
much as possible but there's only so
much we can do this I believe it was a
50% shade cloth so that really ended up
being you know at the at the end of
harvest cycle 3 we were providing half
as much light or needed to provide half
as much light so the statistical
analysis for this was performed using
our and we accounted for the effects of
position in the table as well as harvest
cycle one two or three we looked at
lights and variety as well as the
interaction factor between lights and
variety which is very important and we
used ANOVA and predictive models and a
to these HS D and you will see examples
of all of these going forward so just to
start out with first experiment two
results we didn't really find any we're
not many statistically significant
differences which we determined it as to
be an alpha of 0.05 there were high
variability within some varieties and I
chosen to include this table of just raw
weight data so what this is we have the
varieties along the bottom and our
weight in grams on the y-axis and you
can see these box plots represent all of
the raw weight data that we collected
you can see these within the quartiles
there's a large difference from the mean
there's a large range from some of the
varieties where there's a shorter range
from other varieties and this is really
important information for a grower to
have maybe not necessarily as important
academically but for growers they want
to know are we going to be able to rely
on this variety of lettuce to give us
this weight of lettuce consistently or
are we going to sometimes sea lettuce of
this size or that size so having this
for this information was important for
them but of course we wanted to know
statistically significant data so for us
with a Tukey's HSD test we identified
approximately well eight four right
eight groups but there was a lot of
overlap with pretty much all of her
varieties there was only one variety
that had a statistically significant
difference in means here where the led
was significantly smaller than the high
pressure sodium this is likely due to
the fact that Theodore had a huge
problem with bolting under the high
pressure sodium lights so consistently
we would see at this point at harvest
point we would see bolted lettuce under
TV or with these really long stalks
really long flower stalks and the high
pressure sodium or the led may have just
begun to bolt so that added to our
problems here we couldn't really say you
know is this usable head weight for
bricks and glucose we didn't really find
any interesting trends we looked at for
example this graph is our bricks by just
percent bricks and then our glucose
which we measured we using a OneTouch a
blood glucose meter which may or may not
have been the best tool for the job but
we were looking for a different data in
some way to equate Brix percent total
dissolved solids to a sweetness factor
which glucose may have been a way to do
that we didn't really find any
relationship between bricks and glucose
we also looked at the relationship
between bricks and variety we looked at
the relationship between glucose and
variety we also looked at lights and
bricks and you know I lights and glucose
and there wasn't really anything that we
found that was interesting so we decided
to ditch this and move on for cycle 2 we
looked at taste test data where I went
to dr. Matson's hydroponic lab and set
up this taste test where we took one
head from each variety and from each
each treatment so we had 26 heads of
lettuce and they were not labeled high
pressure sodium or LED but they were
labeled a or b so a blind test they were
told the variety and they were told to
fill out a worksheet with three
different categories color texture and
taste and given an explanation of what
each factor meant within each category
there weren't really very many
statistically significant results here
we used a chi-square analysis there were
only three that were interesting
two of them were color which we sort of
expected to see rousai and Seurat are
both red leaf lettuce and we both are we
expected to see that under LEDs we would
see more red than under high pressure
sodium simply due to the larger amount
of blue light provided by our LED
treatment and again with paste only TDR
Theodore really showed a difference at
all being more bitter under the high
pressure sodium than under the LED and
again this wasn't really surprising
because theater was bolting at the time
and as lettuce begin to bolt they tend
to get more bitter and taste really
gross that's why we don't want to eat
bolting lettuce and finally for cycle 3
we chose to look at height and diameter
and for diameter we didn't really notice
any significant differences some were
cloaks but nothing below an alpha of 0.1
so we didn't mention them here but there
were some significant differences in
height so for this table
you got variety we have a high-pressure
sodium height we have our LED height and
the p-value of the difference between
the two so typically our high pressure
sodium was taller than our LEDs by 2 to
4 centimeters depending on the variety
but again this is 4 out of 13 varieties
that showed some sort of difference here
still an interesting difference and one
of the reasons why we chose going
forward to look into that more closely
and finally for electrical efficacy this
might be a new term for some of you what
we chose to define as electrical
efficacy was biomass efficacy or grams
of edible mass produced per
kilowatt-hour used and the way we got
that was we summed all of our edible
biomass produce regardless of variety
for treatment
and then with our our lighting algorithm
we were able to track how many hours on
our our lights spent on and track how
much how many kilowatt hours actually
drew during that time so we could come
up with this number of grams of edible
mass that we have divided by the
kilowatt hour that that array that
treatment actually drew during the
entire harvest period and what we found
wasn't too surprising but it is still an
important fine was that LEDs tended to
produce two to three more times
edible mass per kilowatt hour used now
if you're just looking at the edible
mass produced they look pretty similar
right but the LEDs are using less
electricity on a day to day basis simply
because they tend to draw less
electricity than the high pressure
sodium and based on this we would make
some recommendations of using LEDs
during the summer to save on electrical
cost or in the winter if heat production
is not an issue and I bring up heat
production because high pressure sodium
tend to be very warm light and during
the winter some greenhouse managers
really appreciate that because having
the lights on does help manage
greenhouse temperature again another
recommendation is that LEDs can
potentially improve red pigment
production which based on our taste test
and consumer responses we can see some
evidence of that but it does require
more of an in-depth look at pigment
production and analysis so for
experiment three this went from June to
September of 2018 and this was also
three harvest cycles and what we did for
this was we went down to six varieties
so like I said before in harvest cycle
or in experiment 2 we knew we were going
to get very strong statistical data
because of our sample size but at this
point we wanted to be able to increase
our sample size by more than double and
really pick which of the morphological
factors we wanted to look more deeply
into so here again we still have the 210
channel treatments and some helpers are
included
year and I had a lot of help privacy
these were a lot of plants and so with
this cycle these were summer months so
shade cloth was closed again and we were
still sort of worried that our lighting
treatment would be a little bit diluted
by the ambient light increase the
objective again Bettles better
statistical data and evaluating
specifically yield and size so the
height and diameter is what we ended up
focusing on here so for the experiment
three results again we didn't really
find any significant differences in
yield and what this is this is our six
varieties here crunchity a green star
Locarno ricks from science Andhra to red
varieties to green varieties one remain
one large open leaf head and you can
still see they're pretty we've got a
pretty good distribution of different
sizes some varieties were larger under
high pressure sodium some under led and
some were pretty equal so you know
nothing really to be said at that point
however when we start to look at height
we do see some differences here that
these are statistically significant less
than an alpha of 0.05 so for a green
star are very large head you can see
there was a very large difference in
Xandra one of our red varieties also a
very large separation between
high-pressure sodium and led the
high-pressure sodium tended to be taller
which with lettuce how we measured that
was chopping off the lettuce heads at
the base of the channel and measuring
just from the top from the bottom to the
tallest point on the head so not
necessarily the inter stock height so
what we attributed this to was
potentially the factor of the increased
blue light from the LEDs blue light
tends to inhibit stem elongation and
this may have inhibited this may have
been the factor that was playing the
largest role and our height difference
for the lettuce and with the diameter we
saw even more variety showed us
significant difference
um again it was crunchy de Greenstar
Locarno and sandra only one of our red
varieties although the other one looks
like you know there were still
differences between these two they just
weren't statistically significant and
what we could attribute this to was
potentially so for this one what we saw
was a lot of times we had our high
pressure sodium the the wider head of
lettuce not in all cases with Conchita
but this tended to have a more compact
and upright form already as a romaine
head but red light red light and far red
light tend to promote greater leaf
expansion which may have been the cause
of this one the green star Locarno in
sandra all were very open heads of
lettuce
so with those wider leaves they may have
the far red and red in the high pressure
sodium definitely may have encouraged
greater lease extension there so for our
conclusions yield really didn't show
much of a difference between high
pressure sodium an LED so you can
probably grow pretty comparable weights
of lettuce heads whether you're growing
under high pressure sodium or led some
morphological features were affected but
the practical significance of this could
be argued because the difference tended
to be somewhere between one and four
centimeters
these weren't drastically larger heads
of lettuce but statistically it was
significant and by producing lettuce of
comparable size LEDs can save a
significant amount of electricity as we
saw with the biomass efficacy numbers
and this may recommend it as a really
good source of supplemental light
hydroponic lettuce in the greenhouse
future work this project leaves open
some areas of Investigation for
anthocyanin production between red red
varieties of lettuce we grew a very
large number of red heads and they all
showed a very different pigment
production response so that would be an
interesting area
investigation we could potentially go
through different ratios of red and blue
we only investigated one a 20% blue 80%
red and we could also go through
seasonal comparisons where we choose one
experiment and grow it all year long
instead of just doing three harvest
cycles so moving on to Tomatoes
what we were concerned with in tomatoes
is not necessarily a supplemental light
source but we used LEDs as a sole source
light and we grew micro Tom's looking at
the response of tomato growth yield and
a sorbic acid content in response to
different red and blue light ratios but
why did we want to do this well this
project came out of a proposal that we
designed or NASA initially in 2016 we
applied to have the micro Tom's be used
in the as a sort as a source of as a
fresh source of vitamin C potentially as
a crop to be grown on the international
space station
there are several plant production
facilities that NASA is pursuing one of
which is the advanced plant habitat or
the APH pictured here this is quote
large plant production but as you can
see it's still a very small small system
43 centimeters by 43 centimeters so a
large plant is very relative and the
reason for this is they do conduct
active plant science research up on the
international space station and pursuing
at fruiting and flowering crops as a
source of fresh vitamin C is important
for potential long-duration space
missions or anywhere that you know fresh
fresh produce may not be available on us
signature on a consistent basis or where
supplements may have time to degrade on
the shelf or in storage so what we
looked at was um we started growing
micro Tom's which is a call to a dwarf
to determinate cultivar of Tomatoes
this took place between December 2017 to
October 2018 s this is almost a year
this was conducted in the growth
chambers at Kenneth's post labs two
chambers in fact and each chamber had
two lighting treatments and they were
both set up pretty much like this
we had our table where this is the
seedlings the plants shown at the
seedling stage and we had our lighting
treatments so two bars represents one
light delivering one treatment and
behind this is a another similarly setup
light system with a physical divide in
between the two and performing some
light spillage measurements we found
that the overlap really was only one to
five micromoles so it was really a very
small amount of light spillage between
the two with this physical barrier there
so we performed three replicates of this
experiment they were seated into these
flats they were transplanted in the
4-inch pots and then six inch pots and
again the lighting treatments I will go
into further detail with that in a
second
but what we collected was data on
seedling height true yield statistics
bricks a sorbic acid and fruit and
flower count our set points were air
temperature of 22 to 24 degrees C and
our relative humidity it was 30 to 35
percent so what were our treatments each
of those lights delivered a different
lighting treatment to our plants there
were four total and what we were looking
at was how do varying levels of blue
light affect these different factors
that I just mentioned so we had a 55%
red 45% blue treatment 70% red 30% blue
and 90% red 10% blue with our blue light
being at about 440 and our red light
being at about 6:30 for our control we
had a 45 percent white 55% red treatment
where our white was this broad spectrum
4100 Kelvin color temperature and
our red filling up the rest where each
of the lightening treatments supplied
300 micro moles of light for 14 hours a
day a statistical analysis we took into
effect took into account effective
chamber was it in 16 or 18 which harvest
cycle one two or three that would be one
of the replicates a harvest number
seedling group and treatment when the
four again we used ANOVA and a two E's
HSD four results the fruit side our
fruity old brakes number of fruit and
fruit sides we didn't see any
statistically significant differences at
all and this is most of the harvest
statistics that I mentioned previously
however we did see a couple of
statistically significant differences in
seedling height here we have our height
data over time so seedling height
measurements were conducted over a
period of three weeks within each of the
three replicates and on day one after
transplant into the chambers at day
eight so the next week in day fifteen a
week after that seedlings were measured
and we found that the controlled
treatment and the medium blue treatments
were tallest over time with high blue
being the shortest and this is generally
what we would have expected for this but
not quite as strong and the reason for
this may have been because we did not
germinate the seedlings under the
treatments we germinated our seedlings
and grew them to about the first true
leaf stage and then we transplanted them
into their treatment cycle or a
treatment area so we may have been
diluting the effect of the lighting
treatments at that stage by waiting that
long to apply the treatments for fruit
and flower count we did find that low
blue and control had the highest number
of flowers for the longest time
so we could say that blue light has an
effect on flowering time in the low blue
or having less blue seems to lead to
more flowers
whereas with medium blue and high blue
we saw the highest number of developing
fruit over time and this could lead us
to think that you know maybe there's
something to do with flower initiation
and maybe fruit set but to really
understand this we have to understand
what the connection is between blue
light and flowering so in Arabidopsis
and long-day plants flowering is
promoted by more blue light but tomato
is add a neutral plant and what has been
seen in the research with that is that
flowers tend to occur sooner with lower
blue light levels so we could say that
blue light is repressing flowering if
you're applying higher and higher
amounts of it and typically the
cryptochrome to reactor is primarily
involved in this flowering response with
blue light so going back to look at this
again what we would say is there's
probably an influence of blue light on
flowering and that we saw more flowers
with the lower amounts of blue light but
fruit set is probably a different
mechanism that may need to be
investigated separately as the the
results don't seem to really jive with
the low blue light being via suppressor
or high blue light being the suppressor
flower for a sorbic acid initially we
found some interesting results from our
replicate to relative a sorbic acid
content we thought you know this looks
like there might be some differences
within the treatments but we can't
really determine what exactly is
happening here this is our low blue or
medium blue and our high blue treatment
and our control there's almost a trend
but this medium blue really kind of
bucks that trend
so with replicate 3 we ended up going
through and doing several more
total acerbic acid concentration
analyses and really didn't find anything
what we could attribute this to is the
fact that a sorbic acid really is
produced in response to stressors
environmental stressors and my plants
really did undergo a lot of
environmental stress unfortunately we
had a powdery mildew outbreak in our
replicate - and in our replicate 3 we
had a pretty severe thrips infestation
leading to a lot of plant damage and
stress so that may have masked or
influenced some of our responses in
terms of a sorbic acid analyses so for
our conclusions for that one the sorbic
acid production is affected by
environmental stressors which may
override the blue light response
increasing levels of blue light can
positively influence a number of fruit
produced but decreased time spent
productive and Micro Tom and consistent
but short-lived fruit production may
make Micro Tom unsuitable for
applications in long-term space missions
so for future work for this one we
probably want to look into how to better
control pests nutritional and
environmental pressures within the
growth chambers you would think that
being in the growth chamber already
would help us to control all of those
environmental stressors but
unfortunately they probably didn't
observe strong enough isolation
protocols a larger sample size on the
acerbic acid analysis would be great our
sample size for all of the acerbic acid
analyses tended to be 6 plants per
treatment with a total sample size of 24
so that's a very small end for this and
it really could have also prevented us
from finding any significant findings we
might want to investigate different
varieties of dwarf Tomatoes I thought
this one was probably our best bet to
actually finding some positive results
we didn't really do any investigations
of any other dwarf varieties but we had
had some suggestions over time of
possible varieties to look into so that
would be a good one an investigation
into the effects of blue light on fruit
set
I don't really know very much about
fruit set and it wasn't really the focus
of my research but we did have that one
finding that may have indicated there
was something going on so more research
either on my end
to see if there is good literature out
there on that would be a good idea or
maybe a whole nother project where they
focus specifically on a fruit set
effects so finally my education chapter
this is what this is what we wanted to
this is what I decided was going to be
very important for me how do I get my
research how do I take my research and
make it more accessible to the next
generation of scientists and
agriculturalists and why is this
important well plant science is when
science and agriculture related degrees
make up less than 10% of the degrees
conferred in the US over time there's a
lot of stuff on this graph of what we
want to pay attention to is biological
and biomedical sciences bottom hereis a
year you can see this line this is the
number of degrees conferred compared to
all of these different degree fields and
biological and biomedical sciences is
already near the bottom of this graph
but that still takes into account
biomedical sciences of course but also
things that aren't necessarily related
to plant science like that sciences
would be in here as well and other
biological fields so my objective with
this chapter was to answer the question
how do we get the next generation
interested in plant science study or
even just science in general just
looking back at this we see engineering
near the bottom as well and this doesn't
even really account for some of the
other sciences we want to start focus
earlier with more interesting
applications really what's going to be
an interesting application for the next
generation and how do we make more
advanced biological concepts biological
science concepts accept accessible to
middle schoolers in particular so in
order to start doing this I look back at
my research and I thought what do they
need to know in order to understand this
well they need to know about
synthesis and photo biology and and
middle schoolers do tend to learn about
this but it certainly isn't a focus they
need to learn about light and light
spectrums understanding what is a graph
like this mean and how does it affect
its environment how does it comment on
its environment interaction with of
light with different materials say for
example how does light interact with
greenhouse materials a technology as
well hydroponics lighting control
systems all of those were used in my
projects as well as environmental
effects we look at things like air
temperature relative humidity we look at
intensity and quality of light we look
at all these things co2 as well so they
need to have an understanding of all of
these things in order to really even
begin to understand the type of research
that was presented today so when I came
up with to sort of guide the discovery
of all these topics with a concept
shoebox photosynthesis and we I decided
to focus on specifically a core activity
or an experiment that can be performed
as a class and the central experience
experiment uses LEDs in a small
classroom environment and I came up with
this little an illustration
unfortunately I haven't had a chance to
actually employ this supplement of
activities so we're just going to tell
you about it today so we are using LEDs
in a shoe box to grow lettuce and really
show how different LED colors can affect
lettuce and in order to do that we chose
red leaf lettuce of course because the
pigment production response of red leaf
lettuce is very well documented and does
happen very quickly and as they go
through this journey they learn about
plant science the nature of light
biology environmental awareness and
critical thinking at least those are the
goals so the framework of these lesson
plants they're given an initial scenario
why is red lettuce red when grown
outdoors but green when grown indoors
students then will grow their own
lettuce seedlings over the
for weeks alongside the teacher lettuce
project which is the shoebox
photosynthesis I mentioned they collect
data on the lettuce they formulate
hypotheses they learn about how to
conduct research and they compare
lettuce performance with a total of 14
lessons some of these are how to go to
synthesis work building a spectroscope
and understanding white understanding
environmental requirements for plant
needs and analyzing class and individual
data on lettuce seedling performance so
a really important context to add to
this is you know you can't just design
classroom curriculum supplements and
just put it out there there are
standards and you have to meet these
standards so what are the current
standards for middle school science
education well currently next generation
science standards is really popular both
state and federal level and what they
say for six to eighth graders is they
really need to focus on these core topic
area structure and function of cells
signal processing awareness of
photosynthesis and cause an effect
relationship between the environment and
organism growth responses so art
curricula our proposed curriculum
supplement does hit all of these points
some of the example excuse me some of
the example lessons of course what do
plants need to grow covers the structure
and function of cells the nature of
light how do plants use light shoe box
light treatment these are all involved
in are these all cover topics that the
next generation science standards Eames
as important however this is only a
curriculum supplement so there are
standards that there are just subject
areas that may not be covered by this
curriculum again with um as a supplement
and in middle school I do remember doing
a lot of these as well and after
speaking with features this is still
apparently the standard people do a lot
of career and personality testing in
middle school and early highs
school they start to learn about college
they start to learn about what are their
interests in potentially furthering
their education or where do they want to
work so this curriculum supplement gives
them some examples of plant science
related areas that they could go into we
talk about things like plant hunters
which sounds really dramatic and of
course this is great to get the middle
schoolers attention where these people
go out into you know potentially not
uncharted but not well-known biological
areas and look for new varieties of
plants and categorize them in herbariums
there's also the space agriculture idea
where there's there's examples like the
lunar greenhouse which I worked on in my
undergrad where they're developing a
greenhouse to grow plants in the Moon or
Mars and then there's also plant
propagation and genetic modification of
crops which of course is a hot-button
topic for a lot of people so they may
have heard of that before going into
this at some point it also plans
in-person visits to real local research
or production centers to give them an
idea of what this actually looks like if
they were to see something someone doing
something for plant science on a
day-to-day basis so conclusions in
future work for this one meeting current
science standards for teaching while
using plants and plant science can be
done for middle schoolers and their
conclusions of this or the results of
this are to be determined
so future work would really be you know
testing it in the field actually finding
some teachers who wanted to do something
like this and going through the
curriculum and seeing how it actually
worked we would also want to gather
opinions from current teachers on the
viability of this curriculum and
interest in this type of curriculum
supplements we really want to answer the
question going forward of how do we
balance the study of plants with study
of humans and other animals because
plants are often left behind a little
bit when you're studying biology in
middle school or high school and we want
to we want to fix that so
acknowledgments of course I want to
thank my committee dr. Madsen dr.
Timmons and dr.
Paree thank you very much and gloomy
girl CEA fresh farms Francois Chris
statistics help I could not have done it
without her if he needs to t6 help
definitely go see her and of course the
entire Matson lab everybody listed here
was at some point or another enlisted
for data collection activities and I
really appreciate that and of course all
of the greenhouse staff who helped me
care for my see lengthen my plants on a
daily and weekly basis alright with that
I open the floor to questions
[Applause]
we'll take general questions now and
then we're in detail committee questions
afterwards any questions yes because I
felt like looking at my research I
wanted to introduce some more complex
topics and I felt like that was the
point at which you start to be able to
have them do some more interesting
activities and give them a little bit of
time to actually like do some more
reading based research as well there's a
component where they do have to do some
library and internet research as well
and they do a little bit of writing so I
felt like that was the level where they
could start to handle that type of work
so looking at the cost of implementing
those systems I I did do a little bit of
that mostly what I focused on was the
physical cost there wasn't any thought
of pH meters for example the systems we
were looking at a very very rudimentary
it would just be buying little LED
boards very small ones the hobbyist ones
are actually available for reasonable
prices 10 to 20 dollars each sometimes
less and cost of materials such as seeds
or you know the cups the shoeboxes
stuff like that it's it's not too much
but there was some done so I didn't
recommend that they buy things like pH
meters because I knew that would be too
much but LED boards would give enough
light to actually grow plants um I think
they would give in the distance they are
from the plant within the shoe box
they're less than a foot typically a
distance from the bottom of the shoe box
and then you add the cup and the pellet
that they're grown in they're an inch or
two higher you can even increase or
decrease the distance by boosting up the
plant that you're growing with some just
something else to make it higher
underneath but for in general like to
grow a really big head of lettuce no
they're not gonna provide enough light
but seedling stage and baby leaf stage
probably will be okay
definitely not commercial quality but
enough to show growth in response to the
light yeah for weeks
yeah yeah probably and that's about
enough to make a large seedling so
anyone else okay yes you wow this they
answered all your questions thank you
for coming and
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu